est-ce qu'il ya d'autres personnes qui
ont fait des pubs autour de la table
finale viennent je pense quoi ya
longtemps et ouais alors l'europe vous
cdd pub plutôt luxe plutôt classe
c'était pas rigolo est ce que quelqu'un
d'autre a fait des pubs donc la table
maintien qui bat alors si je vous dis
céréales au cas de chocolat mathieu
malheur attendre la phase est celle
estate les américains n'ont résisté pour
m'avoir il fallait une figure par pays
bruce willis avait fait les states et
sam mendes que ça la france jusque chez
vous oubliez le dossier ouf
mais ces gènes on a trouvé mieux
les énoncés tu es mal écrit sagem pas
revoir et nouveaux trésors chaud pour ce
volet que l on ressent de tous mais il
cache une surprise à chaque cuillère une
surprise à chaque cuiller céréales au
chocolat
il nous faut matthieu delormeau si tu
devais passer qu'un petit bout parce que
c'était des céréales moins sucré voilà
en fait j'aime paris à des tarifs mais
c'était c'était des voilà un beau
produit en hlm âgées j'avais encore les
petits cheveux blonds tout ça et ouais
enfin tu tes cheveux blond naturel avant
la décoloration
évidemment il y avait du soleil énergie
douce jilin ont voulu dire quelque chose
ah non je vais réveiller pas bon non
mais je trouve très bien est ce que vous
êtes chauffé jeu c'est extrêmement sa
part attend au jeu de comédiens par
rapport aux céréales qu'est ce qui vous
choque
je comprends pas qu'on puisse se
remettre d'avoir fait une pub comme ça
les céréales lui rapporter du blé non
vaut mieux et de chair se passe-t-il au
travers des publicités plus qu'à par
jean michel et moi et pardon vous aime
beaucoup d autres sont pas connues te
fait quoi on ne vous et pour vous c'est
quoi isabelle l'élément tests
électriques lors des cinq jours de
combats avec wade s'est dit heureux et
les cannes les couches pour future in r
non c'est pareil pour moi non je vois
moi je m'en fous j'ai 56 ans venu dit on
paie pour les laxatifs s'est séparé mais
non maison pour sa part au match quand
j'étais plus jeune on m'a proposé une
foule pour les rouges à lèvres et j'ai
refusé à la guerre vous réserviez pour
les laxatifs mois non non il est trop
coûteux et pourquoi pas proposer sa plus
jeune va bien quand j'avais 20 ans
j'étais hyper comme en anglais